you take advantage of women Jordan in
this
go tell Taylor right now while you're in
there let's talk about some drama you
have it was pretty unexpected John Paul
Jones versus Derek two people we did not
think would fight in Paradise what was
that fight like for you in the moment
watching it he seems like a different
person kind of unhinged I thought at
first we were gonna sit down and have a
nice conversation I don't know if you
noticed that but I was like yeah dude
let's let's go talk so I felt like I was
driving along in a truck hit me was very
unprepared for any of that and it's just
so weird to watch back so my dear let me
ask you about that fight with Derek any
regrets on that it looked like you
weren't really yourself you came a
little bit unhinged honestly that was
not the jpg we knew yeah again I didn't
say anything that was false everything I
said was true
you were saying you didn't say anything
false about Derek right and again you
know being inclusive and being a very
laid back it's part of my personal
culture I think a lot of people would
agree with that and I try to avoid drama
and any unnecessary confrontation and
it's just unfortunate that Taoiseach had
to get it was do you think Derek's a
frat boy who hooks up with fans or do
you think he's a good guy these days I'm
like Derek's a bad guy at all you know
it's just unfortunate that you know my
love interest was involved and you know
I had her best interest in mind so I had
to had to stick up for her yes for the
record are you somebody who hooks up
with fans who listen to your podcast and
DM you officially I have never hooked up
with a podcast fan ever that is on the
record you've heard it here absolutely
not
tune in to the big finale Tuesday
September 17th on ABC to see how all of
the drama shakes out
[Music]